hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legend of korra episode 8 video so
i know there was a little bit of
confusion it was a clip show Bryan
Konietzko totally explained it so I'll
do a breakdown of what he said even
though there wasn't a ton of new footage
I did enjoy the way that they presented
the old stuff they even tease some
things that we've been asking for for a
long time so see clip shows don't have
to be all bad but careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
starting with top five moments number
five Bryan Konietzko explains the clip
show
so essentially what he said is is that
nickelodeon slashed their budget they
found out at the last minute and they
would have either had to fire everyone
on their staff a week early or use a
clip show break treats their crew like
family so they were never gonna fire
everyone a week early for everyone
that's asking why it was necessary for
them to do an episode when they could
have just skipped episode 8 and gone
straight to episode 9 Nickelodeon
ordered a specific amount of episodes so
that they didn't deliver this episode
Nickelodeon could have sued them for
example they needed to deliver 13
episodes for book fort to complete
Nickelodeon's contract with them so when
Nickelodeon slashed their budget before
book 4 started production they still had
to deliver 13 episodes but the crew
they'd hired in the workflow that they
had like the way they developed episodes
was based on what book threes budget was
so there really wasn't a way around this
that didn't include firing people or
using a clip show they couldn't just
skip the episode and not include it clip
shows can be kind of dumb so they tried
as hard as they could to make it not
suck they did reference that Nickelodeon
kind of pulled the rug out from under
him the higher ups they also reminded us
the anime shows do this all the time the
example that they specifically reference
was samurai champloo as a show that did
clip shows in a really good way so they
tried to model this episode based on
that I feel like this is the point where
everyone's gonna queue up some samurai
champloo to see what the reference
material look like it's a great series
you should check it out if you haven't
watched it yet and since we're all fans
of Last Airbender we can think of this
as like an ember island players episode
I know a lot of you have already
commented that you felt like ember
island was a little bit more enjoyable
than this episode I will say yes that
episode was a little bit more fun just
because the tone was lighter just
because of the tone of book 4 in general
and what's happened in the last couple
of episodes
everyone was a bit of a debbie downer in
this episode even though they tried to
include some hopeful moments so as crazy
as it is that we had to get a clip show
this close to the final episodes of
legend decor ever it's just a reality of
the business it's like a very Hollywood
type thing you know budgets get slashed
and they have to deal with it number
four Mach Oh explains McCory who else
forgot how relationshipy book one was I
wasn't even making youtube videos when
that was airing that's how long ago that
was the whole point of the Mach owoo
thing was that tagline that he had at
the end I realized I better focus on
being a better King based on book 4 so
far it seems like that's what they're
setting woo up as he will be king but
it'll be a more balanced version of what
the earth Queen was like he won't be as
big of an idiot this is what we're
talking about so he'll never stop being
a complete idiot it's just like the
journey the earth king went on during
avatar last airbender we also get to see
mako's character development he's not
done yet somebody asked David Faustino
if we would see maka cry before the end
of the series and he just responded with
his tweet that said haha hahaha just a
lot of evil cackling I don't expect
there to be any relationship ii stuff in
the finale i mean they'll have some
resolution they'll get some closure
right now Makos still isn't great at
expressing himself so I think by the
last episode he'll get there I mean it's
gonna be the last episode of Legend of
Korra ever so why wouldn't you cry your
eyes out number three Koren Asami not to
be confused with korrasami I actually
tend to use those terms interchangeably
although korrasami means something
completely different this was a bit of a
debbie downer scene
core is mostly looking back at the
things that she's done and thinking of
what Toph said none of it matters
there's never the right amount of
balance
naturally Asami and then Tenzin are
there to slap her in the face just a
little bit book four is all about
balance so it's implied by the end that
there will be the right amount of
balance I don't think they would in the
series without that resolution although
I do think that they'll end things in a
way that will let you know that the
Avatar cycle will continue on in order
for that to happen
they'll have to be a new conflict so
there might be a tease for a new
conflict coming along that they could
just continue in the comics as much as
we've had this big kuvira WTF thing
going on in the swamp I feel like the
end is going to be a compromise she's
not gonna kill kuvira and just squash
everyone in giant energy
number two meta commentary about
overthinking the logic really all my
favorite moments happened during that
last sequence with bolin and varrick
barracks line was probably one of the
most important ones in the episode
don't let truth get in the way of a good
story don't overthink things I feel like
that's bright
talking to the fandom you know just roll
with it don't overthink the logic that
brings up conversations about you know
how powerful is Korra without her past
lives conversations like that arguments
that you get into with other fans some
of the logic that they set up in Legend
of Korra like the past lives raava
avatar Wan has contradicted the logic of
Last Airbender that happens a lot of
times especially with shows that go on
for a long long long time the simpsons
is a really great example of that and
it's also another series that does clip
shows all the time I can only imagine
how bad the quality would dip if the
avatar series went on for 20 years my
number one absolute favorite moment from
this episode though was the alleged -
Korra movie the greatest mover ever made
that's as close as we're gonna get to a
Legend of Korra movie and it's actually
a pretty awesome movie who knew it would
turn out to be such a comedy one of my
big hopes for Bolin was that after the
events of book 4 were over he would go
on to become a mover star like he and
Varrick would just go on and make movers
farik is a scientist and a businessman
so he'll probably do all kinds of stuff
Bolin you know who knows maybe he'll
start of lava bending Academy Toph
started to metal bending Academy
hopefully there'll be some movers in
there somewhere
it was so funny that they got all the
original actors to come back and do that
fill-in scene with the phone
conversation I love that collectively as
a group of villains they all hate
interlocked but they still think that he
sucks
he's like the butters of their group
just in general though for what they had
to work with I felt like it was a great
episode
you know clip show it kind of sucks this
close to the finale but I feel like they
still did a really really good job with
it let me know though what was your
favorite moment and if we actually did
get a Legend of Korra movie do you want
it to look something like this you know
would you be happy with a comedy like
this so just a quick reminder next week
is probably just gonna be episode 9 and
then the week after that there's a
theory they're gonna post all four of
the final episodes at the same time and
do it like a two-hour finale situation
obviously it's all streaming online if
you are watching on TV or if you have
been watching online they're gonna start
airing it on Nicktoons on November 28th
and a lot of you are wondering about
avatar videos after book 4 is done I
will continue to do videos for the new
comics and I'll still do bonus videos
for Last Airbender Legend of Korra I
never did make videos for Last Airbender
or even book 1 so I might go back and do
that at some point there's all kinds of
fun stuff we can do I will be doing a
tech on Titan videos whenever Season 2
comes around if there are any other
really big anime series that you think I
should do videos for just leave me
recommendations in the comments I'm
totally open to anything as long as
there's consensus you know I want to do
something that everyone is gonna enjoy
real quick heads up if you guys haven't
seen me talk about it in my other videos
if you're watching on your mobile phone
or on a tablet you to give me a new beta
feature to play with
there's just links up here it's the same
as the links that I post over here which
will still be the same but right now you
can click here for last week's Legend of
Korra and you can click here for the Q&A
that I'll post tomorrow thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
I will see you guys tonight
[Music]